- My name is Guillaume, I am 29 years old,
and I created an NGO called
Singa in France, starting,
now it's in six different countries,
and basically, what we
do is connect refugees
with members of other societies
around stuff that they love
or on things that they do.
What I'm interested in is innovation,
is also a sense of
justice in our societies,
and when I started working Australia,
I started to get in touch
with a lot of refugees
and asylum seekers, and they told me about
all the dreams that they had,
and I realized that nobody
was actually interested
in that kind of issues, they
were always taking about
admin, about the legal
aspects of seeking asylum.
But nobody was talking
about how you unlock
the potential of people,
and how you rebuild
the potential in a society.
What we're trying to
achieve is to make sure that
local people actually really understand
what they're going through and
what they could do about it.
And it's really about crowdsourcing,
because it's more important
to actually meet someone
who works in the same field than you
than to go ten times to the job center.
One of the biggest
challenges, the fact that it's
a really political topic,
so when I started saying,
it's about citizenship
and it's about innovation
and it's about a lot of different things,
people always go back to, y'know,
a debate about whether
refugees are welcome or not.
And I think that's not the question,
the question is how you
make sure that if you have
people on your territory, you create
connections with locals, but also,
you make sure that they can
contribute to that society.
Today, Singa exists in
four cities in France,
but we have people telling
us, we want to start
your organization in Bedoin, Ajain,
in a lot of different cities.
So, we're changing our job,
we have been for a long time.
People who were organizing events,
people were connecting ourself,
and now we are going to be supporting
local people who do that.
So the idea is to be present
in thousands of cities in 2020.
The fact that every day
I'm learning something,
the fact that every day
I'm meeting with a chef,
an engineer, that's why
I'm continuing this,
it's amazing.